[Music]
it's a unique
look at the intimate moments of the
lives of many of us who've been
affected by the the there's
just been so many misconceptions about
me
so i wanted to show people who i really
was we knew it was going to happen
so don't lose hope love conquers all i
truly believe that
the representatives of the british
people in terms of lawmaking
are the british commons
okay
[Music]
now the queen says she has been inspired
by how the british people have pulled
through the coronavirus lockdown
as the duchess of cambridge launches a
digital photography gallery
back in may the duchess asked the public
to submit photographs to paint a
portrait of the nation
and to record the the fierce hopes and
feelings across generations
during the course of the pandemic well
the final digital exhibition which you
can
see some of the shots from is being run
in partnership with the national
portrait gallery
it's called hold still and over 31
000 images whittled down to 100
of the most evocative pictures let's go
live to hackney and then we can talk to
one of the judges the poet and writer
lemsi say let me say welcome to you
thank you very much for joining us today
that was that was a lot of winnowing
down over 30 000
pictures to go did you go through them
all yes we did
and uh it was a very moving
one of the um pieces of advice we were
given is as we were going through the 31
000 photographs that we sh we may need
to take a break
and i would say that anybody who looks
at this exhibition at the national
portrait gallery website
you may need to take a break as well
because it's incredibly
emotional incredibly moving
it's a unique look into the lives
of the intimate moments
of the lives of many of us who've been
affected by the
the pandemic it's sort of what the whole
nation to some degree has done
during parts of the last six months as
well you know this idea that we've
all had to hold still perhaps become a
little more introspective
and here's an opportunity for for people
to curate their lives in this way in a
way that of course
you know smartphones now allow us to in
a way that wasn't true
in quite the same way say 20 years ago
well
we take we make jokes don't we about the
the the self-regeneration
when in fact that same tool the the
portrait
has become an incredibly important way
of us seeing each other
of us being touched even though we can't
touch each other
we can be touched by seeing our
an experience in our separation we have
lived
through this pandemic in our individual
lives
this is the opportunity for us to see
each other
you were asked not to judge them so much
on technical merit on
on the things that photographs would
necessarily be judged on but to judge
them on the emotion
but nevertheless a lot of these photos
look very very accomplished
all arts should move
the person who's experiencing it uh
however
technically brilliant it is if it
doesn't move you if you don't
if you're not moved to laughter there is
joy in these photographs
to tears there is pain and loss in these
photographs
the photograph of the two the couple
holding
hands in the hospital um the
the workers had pushed their beds
together so that they could hold hands
and in the description it says this is a
picture of my mother
she died two days after this photograph
and this is my father
he died a week after her the photograph
is a way the portrait is a way of
holding
our nation and the people of our nation
in mind in those
incredible moments of adversity through
throughout this pandemic
[Music]
well now the united nations is
celebrating the fifth anniversary of its
sustainable development goals it's a
program which aims to achieve a better
and more sustainable future well to mark
the event the un has made a 30-minute
film which tells the story
of the world as it is and as it could be
it'll be aired
on sky documentaries as well as the un's
youtube channel in a moment
i'll be joined by the un secretary
general antonio gertrus but first
here's a taster of the film
[Music]
this is a very important story
the important story in the midst of
covet 19
it's an historic opportunity to look at
the facts of the world as it is
and then to focus on the solutions to
some of our greatest problems
well i'm joined now from new york by the
united nations secretary general antonio
guetras
very good to talk to you secretary
general thank you very much indeed for
joining us
on sky news and can we start with the
sustainable development goals
17 of them in total but have they been
derailed the progress derailed by the
kovid pandemic
dramatically derailed the pandemic has
shown how vulnerable we are vulnerable
in relation to a microscopic virus that
has put on our ease
vulnerable already in relation to
climate change and many other challenges
that we are facing
and the truth is that all the progress
that was being made in the dedication of
poverty and dedication of hunger
and in many other aspects around the
world all that progress is being put
into question
in some aspects we are moving 25 years
back and now we need to
enhance our efforts and we need to take
profit of the huge mobilization of
resources that
is being done for the recovery to make
sure that those resources are applied in
line
with those sustainable development goals
to have more inclusivity
more equality more equality more justice
and at the same time more sustainability
in the way we prepare our future we
cannot go back to where we were
we need to try to profit of the recovery
in relation to the covet
to build a more sustainable and
inclusive world but are you worried that
developed nations will not be getting
that message they will concentrate on
their own populations
first and foremost in the recovery in
the developing world
will lose out that's the problem we are
facing now
i've asked since the beginning of the
crisis for the mobilization of a rescue
package
of two digits of the global economy
now the truth is that if you look at the
united states or europe
this was done to rescue their own
economies
but if we look at the developing world
the volume of resources mobilized until
now is much smaller
and on top of that many of them have a
dramatic depth problem
there was a suspension of depth for the
least developed countries this is the
group of the poorest countries in the
world
but we need to have much more debt
relief for developing countries and some
middle-income countries
and we need to have a much more relevant
transfer of resources
to those poor countries that are facing
now the impact of the coffee
and the impact in their own economies
and societies
where poverty was already quite dramatic
and where the access
to health to education and to several
other aspects was already lagging behind
in relation to the developed world
[Music]
this september is childhood cancer
awareness month
amid the hardships suffered by young
people and their families affected by
cancer
there are also great stories of
happiness dr catherine poynter has just
finished her phd
and is now working at the hospital where
she was treated after being diagnosed
twice with leukemia as a teenager
and skin cancer aged 26. catherine is
also a researcher for the cancer
research uk children and young people
campaign
to develop better treatments and she
joins me now
let's talk first about you as a patient
you were 14 years old when
your first diagnosis came tell me what
happened
um so it it completely came out of the
blue i
i hadn't been very ill for very long but
i was
very severely ill very suddenly um we
don't have any
family history of any kind of cancer on
either side so
leukemia i at that point i'd never even
heard of leukemia
um so when the the doctors
started taking blood from me to find out
what was wrong and when i got
transferred to a children's cancer ward
that was a real shock to the system
as if that wasn't enough you went
through treatment then again
just a few short years later you had to
go
through it one more time the particular
type of leukemia that i had it's kind of
known that if you relapse
um you're you're in real trouble so
we had to go for a bone marrow
transplant because the chemotherapy was
no longer enough to
to stop this from happening um and we
knew that no one in my family is a match
so we went on the national bone marrow
registry and we were very fortunate that
we managed to find someone quite quickly
who was a very good match for me
bone marrow transplant was just beyond
anything i had ever experienced at that
time
and and you know in amongst all of that
i was missing
a lot of time in school my gcses were
completely disrupted i missed a whole
year
i missed year 10 and then i had to take
a full academic year off in between the
first and second year of a-levels
it didn't stop you though did it you got
your gcses you got your a-levels you
went on to get a biomedical
degree and then age 26 a third diagnosis
it was a very very mild type of skin
cancer nowhere near as
you know nowhere near as serious as the
leukemia was um
it's a it's really at the very periphery
of what we even consider cancer
but nevertheless to be diagnosed with
that and to be told
this has been caused by the radiotherapy
that you had
how much of has what you have been
through informed your career choice in
the direction you want to go in
catherine
oh it's entirely responsible for my
career choice being a cancer researcher
was never on my radar until i went
through it myself
after i had all my treatment and i went
to university i did stay open-minded
about other areas of research and other
diseases but in reality
this is just something that it's
resonates
so much with me that there really was no
other choice
let's go back now to those new covert 19
restrictions
which mean that from tomorrow no more
than six people will be able to meet
inside in england scotland and wales but
not all of boris johnson's mps support
the stricter measures
one of those is the conservative tom
tugan heart who joins me now good
morning to you thank you so much
um for chatting to us this morning so
what are you not happy about
well first of all i do support the idea
that we need to be responsible i think
it's absolutely right
that the government is encouraging that
and i have uh no objection to that at
all
what i am concerned about actually is
slightly different which is the
encouragement to snoop on neighbours
and frankly having a new snoopers
charter is i don't think exactly what we
your son is need you hi morning
can i come downstairs in a minute yeah
i'll do your face painting with it oh
what's his name sorry that's adam oh
bye adam face painted later where do you
get this
um this notion that the government is
asking people to snoop on other people
the representatives of the british
people in terms of lawmaking
you have some tough lawmakers in your
house i see um i just want to um
i just want to talk to you about the um
this um
internal market law and what you think
about it do you think
that it is okay um that
they would be able to break
international law i mean that's what it
comes down to
doesn't it well look governments are
always trying to
balance conflicting pressures between
national and international law
um but i have a real concern and it's
one that i've spoken about with the
government and with the chief whit
uh but i'm not gonna i'm not gonna go
into the details of that
on your channel look please children if
you if you're only no no no you must
stop that
i think we i think we'll leave it there
girl i'm terribly sorry we've now got
jumping on the bed if this is gone okay
we'll leave it there
um i think it's time for some face
painting um tom adam and was it beatrice
adam and beatrice executive yes well
thank you all for coming on and talking
to us this morning
sorry i do apologize not at all thank
you
[Music]
she's best known as the original
influencer as well as being the heiress
to the hilton hotel chain
paris hilton is an accomplished
businesswoman model
and dj now she's trying to clear away
some of the misconceptions about herself
in a new documentary
this is paris but in her only uk
broadcast interview the star
told sky news that the film was also an
opportunity
to address some dark parts of her past
sadia chowdhury has this
a glamorous socialite who's had even the
most intimate details of her life
told over and over again paris hilton
has decided it's time
she tells her story i feel that there's
just been so many misconceptions about
me
so i wanted to show people who i really
was in the film ms hilton will open up
about a sex tape
released by her then boyfriend 16 years
ago
you know back then they
made me like i was the villain and
i'm so grateful that times have changed
and now
women are getting the respect that they
deserve because
i wasn't you know obviously
lucky in that situation but today at
least there's change
so i'm happy for the future of women
that they wouldn't have to go through
something like that because it's
one of my biggest regrets of my life and
something
that will traumatize me for the rest of
my life
born into wealth as the granddaughter of
the founder of the hilton hotels chain
today she's a businesswoman in her own
right
she's worth an estimated 300 million
dollars
but the woman who describes herself as
the original
influencer admits fame and money hasn't
brought her happiness
i'm excited for people to see that there
is so much more to me than
i've ever shown and to see that i'm
a human being just like everyone else
with feelings and
i've been through things i don't have
the perfect life and
told my story is that enough
no
i know that so many of you have been
impacted
by covert 19 and loneliness was
something a lot of us got a taste of
during isolation but for some it's there
every day it's their reality after his
wife died leaving him with no family
tony williams was so
lonely that he resorted to putting a
poster up in his window
asking for friends there he is he's um
75 and since putting up that poster he
has been
inundated with telephone calls what
happened next
here he is hello tony hello hello
how are you i am
absolutely bewildered in many ways but
so pleased
because i've done this for my lovely
lovely wife and i've also
done it for myself really to try and get
people to talk to me to converse with me
and it's been quite a difficult task but
i've cracked it in such a way now than
as you explained earlier
absolutely inundated with calls
emails um and now a few
things in the post and um
it's not just the quantity i've had
thousands and thousands literally of
emails
in fact it's bust my system it's just
i can't use it now but it's also the
um the quality the sincerity
um the empathy that i've had from
literally all over the world
people have written to me emails uh
telephone calls
and they they really feel it as if it's
almost their own grief and i can see
your t-shirt there tony or your
sweatshirt with bahamas is that
somewhere where you went with joe
it was indeed yes we've we've been one
or two
times to the caribbean and
had some lovely weather lovely times um
and i've got photographs of it as a
reminder
yes so um i i'm literally
totally overwhelmed by um
the what i call a tsunami of what's been
happening over the last few days
um i'm very very grateful and in fact
i'm now thinking how we can
tap into this vein of humanity
and sort of feeling of togetherness
um i would hate this to just dissipate
into thin
air what would you say to other people
in a similar position to you
who find themselves on their own and
they just think as you say on your note
there
uh no one to talk to unremitted silence
24 hours a day
unbearable torture well it
my advice is to do what i've done but
not not necessarily in the same way
you've got to somehow go
out and meet people which i found almost
impossible under the
threat of this virus but i determined to
do it
because it was almost killing me sitting
here
in my little room where the phone is
ringing now
and having nobody to talk to the phone
never rang then
but by goodness me it's certainly
ringing now
would you like some good news of course
you would lockdown has seen many special
events including weddings called
off but it's also shown us that love
knows no limits one couple who have kept
an ocean apart by coronavirus
restrictions finally managed to tie the
knot
in scotland priya and sandy had
originally planned to say
i do in malaysia but travel restrictions
brought in
in march have made that impossible and
after months of trying to find an
alternative plan the couple would give
them the go-ahead
to exchange vows in sterling in scotland
and the newlywed couple
join me now from kentucky great to see
you both
and congratulations great news um why
don't we start
priya right at the beginning tell me how
you met because it was quite unusual
i was just trying to kill time in the
heathrow airport and
i opened up this app that i'd heard
about on my trip
from another colleague he said it was
called dill mill
and it's uh just a dating app for south
asian specifically
and i thought oh well you know what the
heck what do i have to lose so
i uh logged onto the app and it's
very neat you've got all sorts of
filters you can filter by height
you can filter by by religion and
whatnot
and you know you can also filter by
location
so i just opened up all my filters and i
only had about a 20 or 30 minute layover
but in that 20 or 30
faded minutes i i happened to
see this beautiful face pop up on the
screen
and i realized oh my god this is you
know this is
this lady is gorgeous and i had to learn
everything about her but there was a
problem wasn't there because
one of you lived in london the other
lived in america
so and then lockdown happened it was the
day i landed in london
um was the day when trump put out his
travel ban and
and that was it i i was stranded i had
no idea where
when i'd see him again the wedding we
had planned in malaysia in may
uh got got cancelled so um
it was dreadful it was the most
difficult part of the story to date so
you were desperate to get married and
prayer i think your dad told you to pull
yourself together and come up with a
solution
uh and you managed to do that tell me
about what you did
i called up pretty much most if not all
councils and all
if not but one um came back which was
sterling and said
we can make this happen and uh that was
the grace
saving grace your heart must go out to
those couples who weren't able to get
married
yes yes i i think we're very aware that
so many
couples are uh in our position and we
just want to give them a sense of hope
that
you know if you put in the effort the
grace will be there and
er things will fall into place and it
will
it will come forward you just have to
put in the effort like
you know i had to go and call the
councils and everything and whatnot but
then
somehow it came and uh everything fell
into place so just
keep the hope i think outside the box i
mean priya and i were
constantly on the phone trying to figure
out how we could get this done it wasn't
a matter of
you know how it was when and it wasn't a
matter of if
it was it was when we knew it was going
to happen so don't lose hope
love conquers all i truly believe that